[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to another edition of the tinfoil
chronicles if you missed the first video
definitely go and check that one out
when you can
but basically what I do in these videos
are go over and discuss a few thoughts
that I've had the tinfoil chronicles are
not well crafted theories with tons of
evidence these are just some things that
I want to mention that are alternatives
to the popular theories that are out
there I'm not saying these things are
going to happen but I think they are
interesting enough for us to explore a
little bit further so let's begin I want
to start this off by getting an
alternative outcome other than the more
popular beliefs that are out there
recently
HBO released 15 new photos that were
taking during the filming of season 7
one of the most talked-about photos was
the one of Jon Snow standing in what
looked to be the crypts of Winterfell
chances are he's just paying his
respects to Ned or Rickon because after
the Battle of the bastards ended Jon
told the men to take richens body down
into the crypts and put him next to his
father so most likely this is what
John's doing in this photo he's paying
his respects and probably reminiscing
one happier time that he had with them
but we all know that Ned is not actually
John's father not only that but we know
his real mother is actually down in
those crypts so when this photo was
released by HBO it made a lot of us very
excited John has been wanting to know
who his real mother is for a very long
time and now that brand knows John's
mother is Liana we are getting closer
and closer to John finally getting some
answers in some closure
as long as brain is able to give him
this big reveal which will make for a
very emotional scene when it finally
happened something I cannot wait to see
but that's not all what also makes this
interesting is the possibility of John
finding something inside of Lyanna
statue something that will reveal who
John's father is which is Rhaegar
Targaryen I think most of us are hoping
that there is a harp or a sword or a
Targaryen wedding cloak or anything that
can further prove that John is actually
a Targaryen if you've watched my video
about Winterfell scripts that I made
months ago then you know that I'm on the
side of the fence of believing something
being down there in the crypts that
proved John as a Targaryen whether
that's in Liana's tomb or down in the
lowest levels where it's partial
collapsed either way I definitely think
something is down there somewhere but
the biggest question is how will John
find this out what will drive him to go
down into the crypts to learn of his
lineage bran stark obviously knows that
Liana is John's mother now so that's the
most likely of answers we all hope at
some point brain can get to John to tell
him what he saw like the Tower of joy
but we have no idea when bran will be
able to do this
we think bran will go back to Winterfell
but we do not know he will go there
right away for a fact I made a video
recently about another way brain could
tell John about his mother without
having to actually be in Winterfell to
tell John I think bran could lead John
down there via a crow just like the
three-eyed raven used to lead brand down
there in season 1 now that brand is the
three-eyed Raven he can relay messages
and information through the crow without
having to risk sending a raven in that
note getting in the wrong hands which
could put John in danger danger that he
wouldn't see coming and some other
people believe that Sam will be the one
to tell John now that Sam is at the
Citadel there was a good chance he could
find some hidden document that can prove
John's 2 lineage and of course another
way could be Howland Reed Howlin Reed
was at the Tower of joy with Ned so he
definitely knows Ned went home with a
baby that day which was Liana's baby
Howlin could definitely confirm to John
that he is not Ned's son but I think
there may be another way John can find
out who his mother is I think John can
still find out who his mother is by the
same man who promised to tell him in the
first place is my mother alive
does she know about me where I am where
I'm going
as you care the next time we see each
other we'll talk about your mother I
promise
Ned made a promise to John that the next
time they see each other he would tell
him about his mother but unfortunately
we know how this part of the story ends
John goes to the wall to become a
brother of the Nights Watch and that
goes to King's Landing where he has
eventually beheaded by the bastard false
King Joffrey this was one of the most
shocking and tragic turn of events not
only because the late great Honorable
Ned Stark was killed but also because
Jon Snow never got those answers he was
looking for and I know a lot of people
say who cares if Jon ever finds out what
purpose does it serve to the story
whether John finds this out I understand
what you're saying but wouldn't you want
to know I personally don't mind spending
a few minutes of Showtime for Jon to
learn of this even though we're running
out of time with only 13 episodes left
it wouldn't bother me to dedicate
several scenes to this I think Jon
deserves to know but you're probably
wondering how the hell Ned Stark can
keep this promise now that he's dead he
promised Jon that the next time they see
each other he would tell him about his
mother well how the hell is he going to
do this now let's first think about the
promise Ned fulfill to Liana she asked
Ned to promise to keep John safe because
if Robert ever found out he would kill
her baby and we definitely know Robert
is willing to do something like this
he wanted Daenerys and her baby killed
so I do think he would have had John
killed too but in order for Ned to keep
this a secret he had to lie too damn
near everyone which is not in Ned's
nature to do that goes against his honor
but if you remember what maester aemon
said to John then you know this was
something Ned was willing to do maester
aemon said what is honor compared to a
woman's love what is Duty against the
feel of a newborn son in your arms or
the memory of a brother smile when then
words
wind in words we are only human and the
gods have fashioned us for love that is
our great glory in our great tragedy Ned
was willing to lie to his best friend
his King which could have gotten himself
killed in order to protect John and
honor his sister's promise Ned was
willing to lie to his wife and bring
great shame to himself because everyone
thought the great Ned Stark cheated on
his wife with some tavern wench Stannis
wasn't fooled though was he but when Ned
brought this baby her
and he lied and said it was his he was
willing to ruin his marriage or at the
very least cause some serious turmoil
within one of those walls what John was
mostly on the receiving end of this but
he did this to keep John safe and
fulfill the promise his sister Lyanna
asked of him now fast forward several
years later to when Ned makes another
promise a promise to John that he would
tell him about his mother when they see
each other again
I think Ned can still live up to this
promise even while being dead but you're
going to have to get your tinfoil out
right now but Ned seems like the type of
man that can live up to a promise even
after death and considering the type of
fantasy world this is pretty much
anything is possible especially with
people who have these prophetic dreams
or premonitions John says something
interesting the same literally that can
provide the answer for how Ned can still
tell John about his mother John says to
Sam all my dreams are of the crips
of the Stone Kings on their Thrones
sometimes I hear Rob's voice and my
father's meaning that stark what if John
has another dream of the crypts and he
heard his father telling him to go down
there to go down to Liana's tomb now
that John is back in Winterfell I think
this is going to stir up a lot of
emotions and memories of Ned especially
now that John is basically turning into
Ned not only that but John is now
sleeping in Ned's bedroom remember Sansa
told him to stay in the master bedroom
because he is a stark he has a start to
her I think with John being in
Winterfell again and possibly even
sleeping in Ned's bed I think there's a
very good chance he can have these types
of dreams or memories of the day Ned
told John he would tell him about his
mother this probably sounds ridiculous
but I still think there was a chance Ned
can keep this promise and tell John
something through a dream just like John
told Sam
when he dreams of the crypts he hears
his father's voice secrets of the
Citadel said if this is John standing at
Liana's tomb in the HBO promo photo then
she thinks something is calling John
there or drawing him to it and I agree
with her if this is John standing in
front of her tomb I think something is
drawing him there too and I think it
could be Ned how crazy would it be if
great
for John Lee's Winterfell to go to
Dragonstone he goes down into the crypts
to pay his respects to his family what
if when he walks past me on his statue
or stands in front of Lee on a statue he
suddenly hears Ned's voice he heard Ned
telling him I promise to tell you about
your mother as he is standing right
there looking at her the next time we
see each other look so goodbye mother
compromise personally I think that would
be absolutely amazing and very emotional
especially if they had the stark theme
playing in the background I know my eyes
would water up but tell me what you
think about this though I know it's
covered in tin foil but damn it I want
John to have some closure and I think
this would be a cool way for Ned to keep
that promise still comment below with
your thoughts as always thanks for
stopping by and spending some time with
me today I want to give a big thank you
to everyone over on patreon your support
means a great deal to me and I cannot
thank you all enough I hope you all have
a good day and I'll see you down in the
comment section bye